hey guys ryan right here what's your
name my name is Justin Melvin Justin
malvinne this is one of my friends who
is not involved in the movie business
everyone thinks I just know like actors
and [ __ ] and Marie but no I know a
little bit more than that Justin and I
asked him to come on this is my idea I'm
not getting paid [ __ ] for this and I
feel like I should for what I'm about to
do but I'm telling you guys right now I
wanted him to come on because he
developed along with his friend Fernando
Fernando right back there he's it he's a
cool he's a cool silent guy today
Fernanda reminds of the kind of guy we
were like go kill that guy he just
walked over and beats him in death or
something that's what he used to do
essentially grabs his base and throws
him into the wall it's like he doesn't
even down yeah he basically created an
app that is awesome but when I first met
him how long had they happen out when i
first met you a couple months couple
months okay that app would like blew my
mind away and then he talked to me about
some youtube information he knew from
their love was just ignited in the air
now every time we talk it's always about
how are we gonna be why are we gonna
move her forward in life in a positive
way this app though is why we're here to
talk this app is called slinger there's
no e in it which why'd you choose to do
that that's just how we roll okay yeah
so you guys think you're like funny and
badass for doing that spelled with an e
it looks all weird you what yeah isn't
it the word with an e normally it's an
actual work right yeah that looks weird
I'm telling okay just so you just don't
agree with it spelling it works linger
like all the posters and everything we
make looks cooler the app looks cooler
with noe and then we just dropped it
okay yeah it kind of sounds like you
guys have a speech impediment no I just
say fling her yeah singapore sling are
it's cool like that sling off its tech
all the tech fans out there you know
it's like you drop have owls out of
there keep it real you're doing a great
job in promoting you're really
connecting with it okay I'd be like the
youth out there I will people to get my
ass
saying is yes yeah that's like how would
you alone is are you want to talk about
deeper into being sling I headquarters
we do have a jolly good time drinking
and making love so this app how about
how about I don't explain this app you
explain the app right so the waste
linger works is if you're at home
sitting on your couch you can see your
friend check in at a bar you can send a
drink directly from the couch straight
to his table at the bar and it happens
instantaneously and is instantly sent so
the app is designed to allow people at
home who you know see that their friends
are out maybe can't join them to shoot
drinks from anywhere in the world their
home you know the car wherever you are
straight to your friends table at the
bar and it started off you know just as
a way for us to sort of like send drinks
to each other when we couldn't be in the
same place what's happened is people
like Ryan I'm join the community and
it's become like a couple you know
thousand people in LA who have started
this culture where you know we add a few
new bars every week people get to go out
and go to new places try new foods new
drinks you know crazy cocktails at some
of the best places in town and you know
we started off just trying to make this
bar up or you could send a girl a drink
basically and it didn't go that way at
all now we're a bunch of people in a
community that are all becoming friends
sending each other drinks and now
there's basically only two kinds of
people in the world there's people who
are you slinger and people who don't and
we're trying to bring as many people
into the into the column a as possible
so that's what we're doing do you end
every conversation with someone with
saying there are two kinds of people
piano to you singer and people who do
yeah and if you're not one of us than
didn't get the [ __ ] out of my face yeah
right now or at least get out of my car
yeah yeah so that's what we're doing
we're doing this video and then Ryan and
I are gonna go out and drink and you
slinger and that's we're gonna do ya
gonna buy him a drink well I'm right
across from him at the table so that's
cool I feel like this can help me get
laid better oh I guarantee you that okay
yeah that's a guarantee yeah so with all
this great information though how much
is this app a dollar two dollars it's
free it's free yep Jesus Christ mother
[ __ ] sometimes you can even send
drinks for free holy [ __ ] guys this is
called genuine enthusiasm
go get this app anyway guys there's very
few apps i actually use tinder match com
grindr followers no subscribers no a
grinder is I hope they do it all means I
Drive you're on Grindr it means yeah
holla back we're gonna go grinder in
like the corner someplace yeah it's
nothing now is that the verb for grinder
I go grinder somewhere yeah that's what
it is I got match com from when i'm
looking to fall in love I got tinder for
you I wanted a turn of the date sucks
i'm on a boner and then I got grinder
for the gay sex yeah yeah straight stuff
is you know preserver yeah I love
romance okay you know just find the
nearest dumpster um no go download that
app Justin he's really one of the
coolest guys have ever known seriously
and that's the only reason I have to be
come by so i could talk about this out
so yeah and i use the app so if you're
in LA or do you even have to be in LA
anywhere dude if we both have slinger
goodbye each other drinks talking to you
Michelle Fernandez talking to you you
don't know who Michelle Fernandez's
drama hot subscribe for Michelle
Fernandez with hollaback lives in
Florida but if you live in favor yeah I
could buy it she can send to you I can't
send her not yet okay but you can buy me
drinks everybody jumps on we'll be able
to get to florida in no time but that's
the point that's the thing how be sure i
need all you guys get ryan download you
have so i can buy drinks for Michelle
yeah and that way we won't have to use
tinder know anymore no except for the
tenders probably really cool no no one
ever likes me back I swipe right without
even looking at the photos just to see
if someone will eventually watch with me
that tender partnership i'm working on
just went straight into this [ __ ] all
hey get on it is always playing
everything thank you guys